now might be magical but even she makes
mistakes and it's probably because
filming a Disney Channel movie is really
hard complicated dance numbers mean that
Mike's jewelry and even people end up
where they're not supposed to be but
what can you do when creating movie
magic isn't quite so simple as waving a
wand
stand back why you'll see in descendants
twos big you and me number everyone's
hair gets wet that's bound to happen
when you're dancing on the deck of a
soaking wet ship but filming a scene
half dry in half what isn't easy that's
probably why the characters especially
mal and Evie go between wet and dry hair
seemingly at random throughout the scene
one second you'll notice that a
character's hair is a little wet and
then moments later it looks freshly
dried this probably happened because of
how many times the director had to reset
the scene when they edited the best
parts together the dancing was a lot
more important than how wet or dry
someone's hair was but the most notable
mistake that we can't ignore is near the
end of the dance number when mouth stops
dancing in the water to run up the steps
her hair goes from absolutely soaked to
perfectly dry pulling out the magic
mouth or did Disney just forget to wet
your hair again sometimes certain
mistakes are hard to notice like a hair
being out of place or a jacket suddenly
missing a button but how hard is it to
notice an entire wardrobe change out of
thin air that's exactly what happened to
dizzy in descendants three during the
performance of good to be bad one moment
she's wearing a loose patchwork dress as
she dances the next second she's wearing
a much nicer version of a patchwork
dress but no one else had sudden costume
changes did the wardrobe department
update her wardrobe halfway through
filming and not notice that her old
clothes were already in the scene since
disease not front and center it might
have been a bit hard for an editor to
spot the mistake and are they really
going to refill a whole section just
because Dizzy's wearing the wrong outfit
in the background but if you have an
eagle eye you probably already spotted
this one and wondered how Disney
overlooked an entire wardrobe change
guess they'll just blame it on magic
I can take you to the enchanted Lake
[Music]
okay so we don't expect a movie about
zombies to be very believable but there
are a few mistakes and zombies that we
just can't stop thinking about and they
both have to do with how weird gravity
seems to work out during fired up so
he's wearing a whistle around her neck
when she goes to do a flip the whistle
seems to stay attached to her shirt but
before and after the scene the whistle
looks like it's pretty loose and wasn't
attached to anything buck he defies
gravity in the same way we see him tuck
his whistle into his shirt but it
doesn't fly out when he's on stage doing
slips and tricks so what gives
well they definitely didn't want
whistles hitting the actors faces so
they probably pinned them to their
wardrobe for the dancing but they could
have just left them pinned so we could
all see how the dancers managed to do it
another gravity-defying scene occurs
when said dancing on a trampoline floor
during BAM the floor sure seems like it
has to be a trampoline since Zed drops
onto his back and bounces right back up
but why don't the other dancers ever
seem to bounce around when they're doing
complicated footwork it looks to us like
only a section was a trampoline or they
replace parts of the floor for certain
scenes it ends up looking awesome but
we'd love to know exactly how they did
it because we're confused boost okay
like what happened to the pep rally
descendants too is a repeat offender the
film might be awesome but continuity
definitely isn't its biggest strength
during chillin like a villain an entire
barrel seems to forget exactly where
it's supposed to be on set then kicks
the barrel when he starts getting into
the performance we see it fly off to the
side out of the dancers way it's gone
for the next few moments but then
suddenly you can see it in the frame
again and it seems a lot closer than it
was before
you'd think they'd mark the floor where
the barrel rolled and make sure to keep
it there every time they reset the scene
but maybe keeping track of a prop just
didn't seem that important plus the
characters leave the area right after to
dance down an alleyway so we put the
barrel pretty far down the list of
important items
Kim Possible does like to make the
impossible happen so maybe this next
mistake was totally on purpose
when Kim decides to try out for the
soccer team she pulls out all of her
best moves including a series of flips
down the field towards the net now first
of all these flips are totally illegal
in a soccer match you have crazy
cheerleading skills Kim but maybe for
the soccer tryouts you should you know
play soccer but illegal soccer moves
aside the other soccer players act a
little strange when Kim starts flipping
around as Kim runs down the field her
opponents are drawing closer but then
when she flips they suddenly all seem a
lot farther back kind of like they knew
it was coming and decided to give her a
room well that's probably exactly what
happened behind the scenes this stunt
double had to do some flips
so everyone needed to get out of her way
Disney just didn't do the best job at
trying to hide it and with Kim that much
in the zone it's not like being closer
would have helped much anyway that was
amazing getting complicated choreography
right is no easy task it's probably even
harder when you're doing it on a sandy
beach under the heat of the Sun maybe
that's why teen beach movie didn't work
too hard to fix a few mistakes in their
performance during surfs crazy Tanner
seems to mess up one of the dance moves
and has to fix it off-screen but what we
see is his body suddenly changing
positions between one second in the next
up first he messes up the drop onto his
surfboard and is half in the sand you
can see that everyone around him is
fully on their surfboard then the camera
zooms in on Mac but when it widens again
we see that Tanner's quickly moved his
whole body onto the surfboard smooth but
we see you Tanner
Mac's performance of Surf's Up also had
a small hiccup you can see her dancing
away and at one point the hem of her
shorts rolls up the very next second
they're back to normal it's got to be
hard to keep your wardrobe in place
while dancing around a beach so we'll
let this one slide everyone remembers
the moment gabriella finally came out of
her shell on stage and performed
breaking free with Troy but one mistake
in this scene makes us think that the
entire
been wrong this whole time if you pay
attention to the scene before Gabriela
gets food you can see that she's the one
about to start the song but after Troy
convinces her to continue he's suddenly
the one starting them off does that mean
the parts they're supposed to sing a
reverse for the entire performance
honestly our minds are blown sure Zack
could have taken the first line to help
her out a bit but it seems like the
sections are split pretty evenly to us
the mistake is probably nothing more
than them wanting to make Gabriela
stage-fright look more intense but now
all we want is a reverse version of
breaking free which is really just an
excuse to hear them sing again she has
an amazing voice perhaps the next music
app in High School Musical 2 when the
gang gathers to sing all-4-one
at the end of the film Chad starts to
get a little bit clumsy his dancing and
singing are on point but it seems like
his mic wasn't quite so into the
performance as he's grabbing his mic
stand the mic topples off and falls
right into the pool well Chad looks like
you have to jump in and grab it wait
it's back already out of thin air the
mic is back to normal and Chad keeps
singing away so why did they keep the
mic fail in when it's so noticeable well
could you imagine having to redo an
entire tape just because the microphones
oh they probably didn't think it was
worth it but now you have two things to
look out for every time you watch this
scene
Chad's magical reappearing Mike and
Miley Cyrus's ICONic cameo Demi Lovato's
breakout rolling Camp Rock will go down
in history as the first time we saw the
superstar sing dance and play the piano
uh except she wasn't doing that last
part in the opening scene of the movie
Mickey's rocking out - who will I be
when she gets inspired to go a little
crazy on the keys but they hand that
slides across the keyboard is definitely
not Mitch's hand first of all the nails
are longer the fingers look different
and the hand definitely belongs to an
older woman it's not strange for a movie
to hire a musical double for some of
their stars but couldn't they have at
least painted the nails the same color
or a made sure that Demi's hands and the
doubles hands were about the same size
maybe they had to find Michi's musical
talents in a pinch but we're not letting
this one get by unnoticed Disney seemed
different
who knew that Olivia and Stella were so
into teleportation you're probably
confused and trying to remember if there
was magic in lemonade mouth but this
teleportation was all behind the scenes
at the end if she's so gone Moe is
belting the final notes of the song and
really getting into it when suddenly the
camera shot widens and Olivia and Stella
have completely changed spots on the
stage and then in the next shot they're
suddenly back to normal unless Stella
and Olivia have been hiding some
SuperSpeed this sudden stage change is
totally impossible do they quickly run
behind Moe and switch spots in the span
of a few seconds then did they race back
to their original spots just to confuse
us the much more likely option is that
the crew set the scene up two different
ways during filming and got a little
confused about which one to use for the
final cut or maybe there was just so
much energy in this version that the
editor just had to use it strange
teleportation aside but it does make us
think
could you imagine Stella and Olivia as
superhero buddies get on it Disney were
you able to spot any of these movie
mistakes during your first watch let us
know in the comments and feel free to
share more of your favorite Disney
Channel goofs don't forget to hit that
like button and subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time